so we had a good year of animating moves
that were just like that doesn't feel
bright that doesn't work we worked on
the axe for so long that there was a
possibility the police were gonna have
to get cut
everybody said look you took three and a
half to four years to do the blade you
are the the axe you're never gonna be
able to do the blades in time hey
everybody
Cory bar log here I'm the director of
God of War and today we're gonna break
down one of the most iconic scenes in
the game the acquisition of the blades
of chaos so this whole opening sequence
this actually did not exist this was a
product of having to cut a huge level
where the Sun was becoming a jerk and we
ended up you know needing to fix and
stitch a bunch of other things together
so this moment where he really rages out
and and for just a brief second is
showing this Kratos inside of him this
moment of realization right is kind of
what I was pitching from the beginning
of the game this idea of how much of
ourselves do we see in our kids and we
usually see some of the worst parts of
ourselves in our kids and I think that
rage that ability to call upon this sort
of godly rage and and set yourself on
fire
that's not something he wants his kid to
have that's definitely a not good thing
and this sequence right here we see at
Reyes looking very sickly he's
completely passed out you don't know if
he's alive or dead
and I really wanted the the effects for
the the you know the all the effects for
his rage mode to fade off very slowly
the idea was that actually holding his
son was the thing that was starting to
calm him down
and when he comes out here this is
really cool you can start to see the the
the red storm and I wanted to sort of
permeate all the way through Midgard
so it felt like is at Reyes actually
causing this and this is just this
intense amount of worry my feeling was I
wanted to go bigger I wanted to go
bigger I think we could get some great
emotion out of Kratos but what was
amazing about this was we held back
what's feel better without having too
much going on but this pacing is very
good you know it's that caged lion feel
because he's faced with a situation that
he's never faced before he can't fight
his way out of this there's really
nothing he can do he has to go to
somebody else that he barely knows to
try to get help and that is a huge deal
for Kratos and throughout the entire
thing we wanted to show that the Red
Storm is really taking over the world
and I want to show a lot of background
animations to signify this and there's
one coming up that we pretty much spent
all our money on so right up here is the
deer and the lightning and that it
running away and we were gonna do all
these animations and then after they did
that one they said that was really
expensive and very difficult so we might
have to start trimming back a bunch now
coming in here this was one of the first
examples of how we were going to hide
any of our warps or cuts because the
actual physical distance that first
lightning bolt the physical distance
between where Kratos starts and where
the house is is really far the the boat
ride would have taken forever so we had
to figure out a way to kind of hide that
and we did it through some of these
lightning bolts that appeared I really
love we can get close on these these
these shots because the model is
absolutely so that one right there is
actually the one where we were doing the
warp so now we see some of the the deer
coming in and everything moving in this
direction right but we were supposed to
have little battles with hell walkers up
here we were gonna have you know hell
walkers maybe killing a deer up here and
kind of just really fill this whole
space all around here was kind of chaos
going around and he has this moment of
calm and I really like the idea that
everything seems to be going to crap all
around him but he's just so focused
because what he's about to do is
emotionally one of the most difficult
things he's going to do so right there
we got one right that appeared because
you know budget like with these grand
ideas of so many things happening and
then you end up really just getting one
or two of these things and he has I
think just a basic Idol
I think in the end sometimes lack of
budget or time constraints they make you
make a decision you wouldn't normally
make but it's for the better I think
that the focus staying on Kratos really
making this somber moment I'm not making
it too chaotic and not introducing
obviously the hell walkers until much
later worked out really well and see
this this is kind of cool we initially
come in and we have kind of a tray Asst
right here in this space and then we see
the body of Fay right here so at the
beginning of the game you're getting
this composition of the door opening up
and creaking open and seeing at Reyes
stand and look in at the body of Fay and
now we're using sort of a negative space
to show that what we have Kratos coming
in to this much darker scenario it's
like every time you go home not
necessarily the greatest thing at the
beginning of the game we actually show
this point so there's a point where he's
closing the door and we kind of tilt the
camera just for a second and then pull
back up and show that the blades were
there and a few people caught it at one
point it was glowing so it was super
obvious you just see this yellow orange
glow coming out of it and this scene
right here Chris judge I had him do this
like two or three times and I didn't
realize how much it was affecting him I
mean he really went deep on this one and
we had to actually rerecord some of the
lines he was saying because he was
actually crying so much during it that
it was harder to catch some of the bits
of Thailand but it was amazing and I
didn't even realize he actually came to
me after we did the third taking he's
like man can I can I get a break I'm a
little worn out and I was like I'm like
I'm a terrible person yes please we need
to take a break down we were very
worried about how we were gonna get
chains wrapping around the arms so
initially we were shooting around that
so we always have this little trick we
have to pulled it at some point they're
sort of already attached right there and
it's just that sleight of hand you have
to pull that is a rigging actual
Grossman as our our technical rigor we
just use a rope on set and kind of
wrapped it around and then they were
able to kind of make that work
this moment for me is such an incredibly
important moment because in that
beginning pitch that I talked to people
about I kept talking about this idea
that it's not like we're gonna erase
Kratos his past it's not like all of a
sudden you started this game and credits
great guy and he's going to saving
people and he's gonna be a good dad
no he's the same guy right it's just
that in the previous games the monster
that was inside of him was let out all
the time and I said in this one he's
making the attempts to actually keep the
monster inside he's struggling and he's
failing constantly but this moment of
accepting that he's a monster right is I
think the crux of everything we did in
this story it was very important that at
that end point he was standing up and
accepting who he is and then he would
just walk straight through Athena
dissipating her and you would be
wandering the entire time was she real
was she in his head or was she real and
in his head I think both of those things
are entirely possible
let's see this is my favorite moment to
watch on the streets I really like
watching the moments that you know
emotionally will get to people you had
gone through all of this wondering
whirring maybe that's not what they're
gonna do I could be reading into this
too much oh my gosh that's what they're
gonna do this is gonna be great and the
payoff that we actually got it right you
know and I think that was always in
question you know we did not do the
blades until probably the last year we
worked on the axe for so long that there
was a possibility the blades are gonna
have to get cut because they were just
taking so long to get on line that
everybody said look you could if you
took three and a half to four years to
do the bleach or the the axe you're
never gonna be able to do the blades in
time so we had a good year of animating
moves that were just like that doesn't
feel right that doesn't work and with
this new camera angle where you have the
camera behind him it's very different
with blades coming out this way and
sweeping out this way
sometimes even across his horizon line
you don't get the same visual as when
you sort of have you know a side view of
Kratos shooting the chain blades out I'm
a really great artist by the way and
people are jealous of my skills but
seeing this from like an isometric view
seeing it from a side view you get a
better view of the line of action for
the chain blades and we really had to
figure out how to take the old mousse
and make them work much better in this
camera angle because so much of the game
was built on this revelation this
realization from Kratos that the blades
were gonna be something he'd have to
return to they were something he want to
get rid of but he'd have to go back to
them he'd have to put them on and he'd
do that for his son he wouldn't do that
for himself but that was part of his
growth this was a very important scene
to me and I think to the entire team to
nail and get right this was a pivotal
moment within the game a huge sort of
crux for the character of kratos you
know we put so much into this that
seeing the reactions was really when it
hit home
we had done you know because you work
for so long you work for five years with
your head down hoping that what you do
actually connects to people and to see
the variety of reactions the way that it
connects to people is is amazing that's
why I love making games because it is so
much about the connection and almost
collaboration with the audience you're
not just creating something in a vacuum
it feels like it for a while but when
you finish when you actually get it out
there it I think it changes you as a
developer it's very good